TO COACH IZZO ON THE PHONE ABOUT
HIM.
WE ALREADY HAD OUR EYE ON HIM.
IT WAS A NO-BRAINER FORGET HIM.
MULTI-FAR AT THE TIME PLAYER
OFFENSIVELY AS WELL, WE ARE
EXCITED TO HAVE HIM.
>> Chris: SMUG SAID RECENTLY
REGARDING RUSSELL WESTBROOK.
AND THAT YOU WATCHED THE LAKERS
LAST YEAR, YOU HAVE A GAME PLAN
FOR HOW TO UTILIZE HIM.
EXPAND ON THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, IN TODAY!!!!!! TOD,
SRUS KNOWN FOR HIS JUST HUGE
COMPETITIVE SPIRIT AND, YOU
KNOW, THE VELOCITY IN WHICH HE
GETS UP AND DOWN THE FLOOR,
PUSHING THE BALL.
THE THING I SAID, YOU JUST HAVE
TO DIVERSIFY THAT.
NOT ONLY WILL HE BE LEADING AND
PUSHING THE BREAK, SCREENING AND
ROLLING, DEFENDING I HAVE A FILM
TOGETHER OF HIM BEING A PITBULL
ON DEFENSE.
GUARDING SCREENERS, GUARD IN
THIS POST AND THAT'S WHERE IT
WILL START.
NOT ONLY FOR RUSS, BUT EVEN,
A.D., BRON, WE GOT A GET BACK TO
PLAYING DEFENSE, THEY WERE
EITHER FIRST OR SECOND IN
DEFENSE THE YEAR THEY WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP IN 2020.
SO THAT'S WHERE IT STARTS, THAT
WHERE YOU YOU MAKE YOUR BIGGEST
CHANGE AND BIGGEST IMPROVEMENT.
AS FAR AS IMPACT STAND POINT,
RUSS IN MY OPINION, HE'S IN
GREAT SHAPE, DURABLE.
THIS SYSTEM HE WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO SCREEN AND ROLL AND
MAKE PLAYS IN THE HALF ROLL.
HE WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO SPRINT
OUT IN THE CORNER, FLATTEN THE
DEFENSE GET CORNER THINGS THREES
AS WELL AS THE THINGS THAT DOES
WELL IN MATERIALS OF GETTING THE
BALL AND PUSHING THE PACE AND
PUSHING THE TEMPO I AM EXCITED
AS HELL TO HAVE RUSSELL
WESTBROOK ON OUR TEAM.
>> Chris: WE KNOW HE WILL PLAY A
BIG PART.
>> Steve: AND A.D. WHEN HE'S
HEALTHY ONE OF THE BEST WE HAVE
SEEN.
HE'S INSIDE, OUTSIDE, AND HE CAN
CONTROL THE GAME.
WHAT HAVE YOU TALKED TO A.D.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SEE WITH
JOURNEY AS YOU AS THE HEAD
COACH.
>> THE JUST BEING HEALTHY.
WE HAVE TO DO OUR JOB AS A
COACHING STAFF, TO YOU KNOW,
HAVE A SOLID PLAN.
HOW WE MANAGE HIS BOD WE WITH
OUR STRENGTH AND CONDITIONING
STAFF, JUST BEING AVAILABLE.
WHEREVER HE'S AVAILABLE HE'S A
PROBLEM.
TOP FIVE PLAYER IN OUR LEAGUE
HANDS DOWN AND HE'S THE FACTOR.
IF HE'S NOT HEALTHY, NONE OF
THIS OTHER STUFF WORKS, MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
BRON WILL BE BRON, BRON WILL BE
GREAT.
RUSS WILL BE RUSS, BUT A.D. IS
THAT PIECE THAT CENTER PIECE ON
THIS TABLE.
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE AVAILABLE
IN ORDER DO WHAT NEED TO DO.
>> Steve: THANKS.